well increasingly we're finding the  lifelong conservatives are switching to  the liberal democrats they're really fed  up the government hasn't done anywhere  near enough on the cost of living uh  they're worried about the crisis in the  nhs they don't like the fact that they  won't stand up to the water companies  are pumping raw sewage into our rivers  well we've argued for a tax cut  a cut in vat worth 600 pounds to the  average family  as well as targeted measures for  pensioners and people who are less well  off and we pay for that with a windfall  tax on the oil and gas companies and not  going ahead with a  tax cut that rishi sunak has put in for  the banks that would fund a real program  of help with tax cuts and the problem is  the conservatives are not helping  they're actually making it worse they're  raising taxes particularly on people on  low incomes this doesn't make sense